cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north bay
pm pour accéder à une grosse promo et
avoir un mois gratuit sur le plan de
deux ans allez sur north vpn point org
slash cyrus north ou utiliser le code
cyrus north
plus d'informations en fin de vidéo
synchronisation est ce que je ne serai
pas le créateur qui insulte le plus sa
communauté je ne sais pas j'ai fait une
vidéo d'abord genre vous n'êtes pas mes
amis elle a super bien marché ça vous a
vraiment plu est là maintenant on est en
train de se demander
enfin je suis en train de me demander si
vous êtes des merdes vraiment cette fois
aucun sens je rappelle rapidement le
concept le concept c'est qu'il ya un
seul président qui s'appelle un média
sol suis-je une merde en gros et on est
parti de sa est en fait on s'est dit que
vas-y ce serait peut être marrant de
lire vos histoires aux lieux lire les
histoires de total inconnu sur internet
a c'est un peu moins des inconnus en
plus ces histoires sont en français il
ya eu des règles très importantes qui
ont été suivis scrupuleusement pour que
vos histoires soit lui d'abord c'est
envoyer un mail à l'adresse suivant
l'envoyer depuis une adresse totalement
anonymisée via un service type ten
minutes ce mail et c'est à dire que si
votre adresse mail est les anonymes du
type je serai un jour c'est un chien
loup @ gmail point com je l'apprends pas
en fait je passe pas ce service là parce
que je ne veux pas pouvoir vous
recontacter je ne peux pas pouvoir être
dans la capacité de vous contacter très
simple parce que si à un moment vous
raconter quelque chose qui est genre
grave j'ai pas envie de me dire ok
peut-être que je devrais rentrer en
contact avec cette personne et les décès
non j'ai pas envie de me donner cette
responsabilité l'envié d'ailleurs le
compte gmail sur lequel vous pouvez
envoyer les mails je le regarde même pas
je n'aime pas accès j'ai filé totalement
les accès à alfie qui monte cette vidéo
évidemment encore du mail il doit y
avoir aucune information qui permet de
vous identifier c'est les règles de base
parce que c'est comme ça en fait c'est
avec ces règles là que moi je me sens à
l'aise bas pour pouvoir dire honnêtement
ou non si vous êtes une merde autres
disclaimer maintenant imaginons que
votre histoire parce vous la
reconnaissez êtes-vous dit [ __ ] si
rudi kuyl merde
c'est juste mon avis je suis sûr que si
on en discute plus longtemps ça serait
peut-être différent peut-être si j'avais
tout le contexte j'en sais rien mais
même dans tous les cas ce n'est qu'un
avis d'une personne c'est pas ça qui va
faire de vous une merde
et même si à un moment où vous avez une
mauvaise action vous êtes une merde
peut-être sur un instant mais ça fait
pas de vous une merde global moi aussi
il ya plein de trucs que j'ai fait dans
ma vie je pense que si je les mettais
dans cette vidéo je dirais de moi-même
grosses merdes voilà assez de 10 km
heure je suis éclatée là il est quelle
heure il est 21h30 je me suis couché à 7
heures du matin on a fait un live
incroyable hier soir sur twitter de 2h30
à 7 heures du matin une radio libre où
vous nous avez raconté vos pires des
hits s'était vanté la folie qu'elle a
mordu à la mort du bien comme il faut
quoi en fait c'est pas tellement la
morsure c'est surtout si le rattraper
c'est vrai mais l'instruit elle était
bien au moins ou pas l'instru était bien
au moins nickel ceux qui me suivent pas
sur tweets vous raté quelque chose je
vous préviens vous raté quelques jeux
venant des partis pour ce tout premier
épisode 2 et et pas le dernier je pense
est ce que vous êtes des merdes j'adore
les êtres le concept j'adore
suis-je une merde pour avoir gardé un
mec qui m'aimait et que je n'aimais pas
juste pour de l'affection car j'avais
trop peur de me retrouver seule
pas besoin de le dire plus avant de
commencer l'histoire sache que parmi mes
amis environ la moitié pense que j'ai
agi comme une [ __ ]
j'ai pas trouvé équivalent de bâtard au
féminin bâtarde vraiment qu'il suffit
juste de rajouter un e bon avancé
bâtarde ap merde est pas mal aussi
puisque ces noms anglais voilà et
l'autre moitié pensent que non peut-être
tu seras les départager aïe aïe aïe je
l'espère mise en contexte je viens
d'avoir 20 ans je n'ai jamais été en
couple de toute ma vie et ça me bouffe
de n'avoir jamais connu ça j'avoue à mon
meilleur ami qui vient tout juste de
partir en voyage à l'étranger pour
quelques mois qu'il m'intéresse
il s'avère que ce n'était pas réciproque
ça arrive ça arrive même aux meilleurs
au moins bon non plus ça arrive à tout
le monde j'espère me trouve un copain
avant que mon meilleur ami rentre de son
voyage afin d'éviter toute gêne en
tonneaux ok pour forcer le destin je
m'inscris sur tender je finis par faire
un des hits avec un garçon il me plaît
physiquement on s'entend bien il s'avère
que je m'intéresse aussi va aller très
vite dans notre relation se mettre en
couple dès les premiers jours rencontrer
nos parents respectifs dès les premiers
mois je comble enfin ce vide en moi de
meuf seul ouais à 20 ans rencontré les
parents dès les premiers mois
c'est rapide de ou vasco temps si tu le
fais genre à 30 ans je ne sais pas
pareil je trouve que les relations
n'avancent pas au même rythme aux
différents âges où est ce que je veux
dire je suis sûr que oui ce que je veux
dire que les rencontres et les parents
au bout de quelques mois à 20 ans waouh
avec c'est sa première relation tout cas
très vite je me rends compte que je ne
tombe pas amoureuse de lui lui est fou
amoureux de moi et moi ce que j'aime
chez lui c'est l'amour qu'il me porte
très belle lucidité un très très belle
lucidité
très vite je me mets à repenser à mon
meilleur ami à d'autres garçons il faut
savoir que j'ai toujours été très
honnête avec lui et je vais toujours
partagé mes doutes et incertitudes les
doutes et incertitudes
je me permets de faire la liste je
pouvais par exemple lui dire que je
savais que c'était pas l'homme de ma vie
et que j'aurai quelqu'un d'autres après
lui
est ce que ces bâtards ça déjà ça dépend
comment celle ci mais bon si on est au
petit déj comme ça c'est le fus d'orange
et au fait tu sais que t'es pas l'homme
de ma vie j'aurai un gars après toi
merci beaucoup de femmes servir les
filets les us te plaît les oeufs
brouillés merci beaucoup mais sciemment
vous avez une discussion sérieuse et que
vie voilà écoute moi je préfère être
honnête fut pas dans un mood où je pense
pas que vraiment nous deux ça va être
pour la vie je perds te le dire parce
que si toi tu te projettes là dedans
après je pousse à toujours délicat ces
questions là parce que je comment tu
sais quoi tu vois genre c'est des fois
t'es pas dans ce mode là et pourtant ça
devient la personne de ta vie tu vois
mais bon de toute façon je trouve que
c'est des questions en vrai qu'en cette
première collation c'est tellement
difficile à gérer
déjà quand c'est à 15e relation tu vois
15 je parlais de relation sérieuse dont
15 sont sérieuses et peut-être un peu
compliqué en terme de temps va juste en
terme de temps à avoir imaginé voilà
sept ans 5e relation sérieuse déjà au
bout de cinq relation sérieuse
je trouve ça hyper dur de voilà de
savoir comment tu te positionnes ce que
tu veux ce que tu attends l'autre
comment ça se passait et tous et a
promis un relation donc non c'est
difficile de dire que que ces bâtards au
bout de 10 mois je dirais je les quitte
et puis très vite il est revenu vers moi
me suppliant de le revoir et j'essaie
des jeux les revues alors que je savais
pertinemment que je l'aimais pas pendant
un an sa durée comme ça on se quittait
en se mettant ensemble toutes les deux
semaines
lui souffre énormément moi ça allait
j'avais mal parce qu'il avait mal mais
en soi j'aimais l'affection qu'ils me
portait en gros lui voulait un couple
moi je veux juste la fiction en
attendant le prochain potentiellement
montmiral aujourd'hui on a vraiment
coupé les ponts ils me contactent
presque plus j'ai déménagé du coup un
mât à soro pour avoir gardé un mec qui
m'aimait et que je n'aimais pas juste
pour de l'affection car j'avais trop
peur de me retrouver seule
sachant que moi je comble et enfin ma
peine de ne pas avoir quelqu'un qui
m'aime et qui s'intéressent à moi je te
remercie déjà pour pour ce poste pour
moi déjà il ya pas mal de d'éléments qui
font que qui te pardonne d'une certaine
manière le fait que soit ta première
relation ça pardonne pas mal de choses
les relations amoureuses un des trucs
les plus compliqués qui existe sur terre
hyper chaud déjà les relations entre
humains
c'est compliqué les relations amoureuses
voilà c'est on fait tous des erreurs on
en a fait plein on en fera ses complexes
quoi la question c'est plutôt à quel
point tu étais lucide de toi tu vas
genre si tu jouissait de
du fait qu'il soit en peine et du fait
qu'il soit malheureux excite il y avait
un sadisme là dedans
oui tu es une énorme merde mais j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit le cas tu vois
j'ai l'impression que tu as appris un
peu ce qui t'arrange et c'est évidemment
on sait pas la manière la plus idéale de
fonctionner je pense que la manière la
plus idéale de fonctionner c'est de dire
bon par respect pour la personne dire
voilà tu veux un truc que moi je peux
pas t'offrirai en fait tu vas souffrir
moi ce que j'ai besoin c'est de la
fiction je peux aller le trouver
ailleurs c'est un gars qui va pas
souffrir du fait que moi j'ai envie de
cette affection ça n'a pas duré trop
longtemps
dois-je ans pas une relation qui n'est
pas un état qui a duré genre des années
des années parce que des fois ça dure
des années
donc pour moi la question c'est à quel
point tu étais lucide du truc
et à quel point tu prenais du plaisir à
le faire souffrir mais par contre était
lucide du truc parce que c'est lui que
la moitié de tes potes trouve que tu es
tu es une merde c'est pas pour rien je
pense tu vois je pense que ça demande
aussi tu vois alors la partie pendant un
an sa durée comme ça on se quitter on se
remettait ensemble toutes les deux
semaines lui souverainement moi ça
allait on se demande aussi de la
maturité
peut-être que tu as veut pas aller parce
que par prendre une décision aussi pour
deux latéraux du point de décision pour
2 francs même si moi je souffre pas il
ya quelqu'un qui souffre dans l'équation
est ce que le manque d'affection que
j'ai vaut le coup que quelqu'un souffre
autant je sais pas après lie à notre
question qui se pose c'est est ce que
j'ai à penser pour le est-ce que c'est
pas la personne qui est responsable de
ses propres choix et donc du coup si
c'est elle qui veut se remettre avec moi
ok mais pour moi c'est un peu trop
complexe pour pouvoir dire comme ça que
tu es une merde aurait pu mieux faire
tu le sais je pense que la prochaine
fois tu feras mieux c'est pas génial
mais jeudi un pacte nerfs suis une merde
pour avoir fait fumer des poils de kujaa
mon colocataire un de mes anciens colocs
et met un peu trop gratter des trucs
officiellement fait plus de coups très
souvent du tabac parfois de la bouffe de
la monnaie et c'est alors que c'est un
vrai raz il comptait tout au moindre
centime
c'était archi lourd surtout qu il se
permettait de gratter très souvent le
genre de mec qui te dit tu te rappelles
tu me devais 37 centimes pour cette
galette
j'avoue moi je percute pas mes trucs en
masse surtout entre potes quoi
après j'ai 30 ans donc c'est plus les
mêmes échelles mais genre même les t
shirt invite un pote à des jets genre tu
la payes et 20 balles c'est ton pote
gros on a en a trente balais tu vois on
a des vies bien rangée on na no tav
évidemment là je te parle avec des
personnes qui ont qui sont en cdi ou qui
ont leur taf qui sont à l'aise tu vois
et à des gars quitteront way la dernière
fois pour le déjeuner du coup j'ai fait
un tri quand gros on est potes ou pas en
fait je ferme la parenthèse
un jour j'en ai eu marre et j'ai mélangé
un vieux paquets de tabac avec une
petite touche paul lemay grosses
couilles une petite touffe de poils de
mes grosses couilles que j'ai gardées à
l'abri jusqu'à ce qu'il me demande à
nouveau au lendemain il est tombé dans
le panneau et là qui fait apparemment
puisqu'il a continué par après suis-je
une belle grosse merde ps mais coup ils
étaient propres et rasés après atteint
une belle grosse merde tu le confronte
tu lui dis voilà tu ai dit ça me gêne ça
me gêne que tu grattes etc mais lui
faire fumer tes poils de couilles tu es
une belle grosse merde tu le sais tu le
sais c'est chiant d'avoir quelqu'un
comme ça dans son entourage et star en
plus et oncologues on ne peut pas
vraiment séparés et ou en tout cas pas
facilement une fois le confronter tu
vois veut dire voilà ça me saoule
en fait ça me saoule soit comme ça et
c'est évidemment de manière non violente
à dire si je vais faire un exemple
je ressens une injustice donc soit tu
pars 20 sentimentaux reçoit toi tu
ressens toi et tu lui dis pas que c'est
lui qui est directement la cause de ce
sentiment livre sans une injustice et la
tei père précis parce que j'ai
l'impression de te donner plein de jour
et quand moi j'ai besoin de quelque
chose comme par exemple 37 100e point de
cannes est battu le donne très
difficilement ou un truc comme ça j'en
serai d'après la direction paraît donc t
elle écoute
tu vois alors on se fait comprendre que
mais faut le faire vite parce qu'en fait
si tu laisses le truc ça prend des
proportions énormes et donc la personne
te saoule en fait faut le faire quand la
personne te plaît encore classe et
oncologues tu l aimes bien et ses effets
d'autres trucs qui sont tués dit se
situe petit rien au bout d'un moment à
un [ __ ] mon collègue qui me saoule
bah ouais mais vas-y il faut lui dire le
plus tôt possible et surtout pas le
faire fumer tes poils de qoui gros suis
une merde pour laisser sombrer ma
cousine dans la drogue what salut sirius
alors elle fit fera attention à ne plus
jamais sélectionné le message on
m'appelle pas par mon prénom stocker
je vais faire court ma cousine a fait
une tentative de suicide il ya peu je
désolé je n'avais pas vu depuis
longtemps gelé revue pour un enterrement
après la mise en bière à l'apéro
vraiment s'est mise en bière et apéro
côte à côte
petite mise en bière
je te mets du porto avec qui veut du
gwec ok attends je viens de capter un
truc c'est ta cousine qui après la mise
en bière à l'apéro ont rigolé parce
qu'on buvait du vin fuit elle m'a emmené
dans un coin et m'a proposé de prendre
avec elle une drogue très spécifiques
après m'avoir parlé de son palmarès deux
toxicomanes j'ai évidemment refusé et
elle m'a fait promettre de n'en parler à
personne de la famille je contiens à
paroles cas pour moi l'honneur et la
confiance est primordiale mais je la
raconter à mes amis pour voir ce que je
devais faire
certaines personnes m'ont dit que je
devais en parler à sa mère car elles
pourraient en mourir d'une overdose une
nouvelle tentative de suicide ou tout
simplement que je la laisse sombrer dans
la drogue dans ma famille il ya eu
beaucoup d'addicts mon père au cannabis
mon oncle est alcoolique et cetera je
pense que le schéma est juste en train
de se reproduire sur un connard de
laisser ma cousine sombré dans la drogue
pour ne pas trahir une promesse war 1 et
dur suivre autant le sarrau suis là
c'est moi je sais ce que j'aurais fait
très envie d'appeler un coup de fil à un
ami là c'est dur vous dire pourquoi
c'est dur parce que effectivement la
personne tu as fait confiance donc
trahir cette confiance bat déjà ça va
lui mettre un coup à cette personne
c'est un coup dont il n'a pas besoin en
ce moment je pense que la prochaine fois
ci se passe un truc plus grave elle le
dira en encore moins de gens et donc il
ya encore moins de gens pour la protéger
et c'est maintenant c'est vrai que en te
disant sa mine de rien tu te retrouve
dans une situation indélicate là c'est
plus je suis une merde insurgés entend
donner des conseils là en fait je en
train de devenir une forme de psy là
j'ai l'impression j'aime pas trop j'aime
pas trop moi j'aime bien quand
l'histoire et fait déjà et je place jugé
facile revenons aux bases de la morale
qu'est ce qu'on aimerait donc si je
pense un impératif catégorique qu'ancien
comment rendre universel ton action est
ce qu'on aimerait que tout le monde ne
disent rien dans ce genre de cas où
est-ce qu'on aimerait que tout le monde
en parle en vrai si je suis quand tu
devrait rien dire et donc tu serais pas
un connard d'après quand parce que pour
pouvoir aider ta cousine tu devrais m'en
tirer on tue brisera la morale pour ça
que d'ailleurs pour beaucoup de gens la
morale qu'ancienne elle n'est pas
applicable
imaginons
on n'est pas rassuré guerre mondiale je
cache des juifs dans ma cave un ss me
demande si je cache des jus dans ma cave
si je dis non techniquement c'est
immoral selon kant
ok c'est un truc que j'explique dans la
vidéo sur kant ou d'ailleurs pour ça que
pour beaucoup de gens il est passé pas
applicable moi je pense qu'il ya
peut-être un antre je pense que tu peux
peut-être aidé la cousine sans trahir
pour autant sa promesse air qui veut
peut-être l'incité elle en parle et donc
de cette manière pour le faire la
meilleure manière possible d'aller voir
un professionnel pour essayer de trouver
la bonne manière d'appréhender les
choses etc
mais je pense que tu peux garder la
promesse et aidé et accusé je pense en
fait après beaucoup de réflexion autour
de cette question
ça a été monté mais j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi je pense que c'est un faux
dilemme je pense que tu peux ne pas la
laisser sombrer dans la drogue tu peux
l'aider en fait
alors jetez pas façon que tu peux
l'aider genre vraiment en la prenant par
la main en la mettant sur tes épaules
externat sais pas voilà tu es pas obligé
d'aller enfin j'en sais rien c'est votre
relation c'est toi c'est comment tu te
sens avec toi et moi l'avs
c'est cet avis tu vois mais tu peux
l'aider d'une certaine manière la
manière que tu souhaites sans trahir sa
promesse mais effectivement je suis pas
sûr que ça serait l'aider véritablement
que de trahir sa promesse en fait tout
dépend comment tu trahis cette promesse
si tu arrives tu donnes un coup de
téléphone à ses parents et que ses
parents et réagissent mal derrière et
qu'en fait projet pas sûr que ça l'aide
suis pas professionnel
et honnêtement les questions d'addiction
on en a déjà parlé dans les amants et
chiasso
etes-vous démerde ou est ce que ces gens
sont des merdes on a déjà parlé de
sélection qui sont hot chip et je suis
sûr qu'en commentaires ya pas mal de
gens qui vont t'aider qui sont soit
passée par là soit donc soit en étant
addict soit en ayant connu quelqu'un
d'addicts et qui ont pouvoir te donner
d'excellents conseils j'en suis certain
avant qu'on se quitte je vous présente
quelques uns
salut je suis ici russe north vpn nord
bpn vous savez ce que c'est vous savez
pas ce que c'est énorme et pn c'est un
vpn virtual private network réseau
virtuel privé ce qui vous permet de
surfer sur le web en sécurité de vous
anonymisées etc
notamment si votre wifi n'est pas
sécurisé et que vous aller sur des sites
qui ne sont pas en https si pigments
vous êtes dans un restaurant moi aussi
ça manque
moi aussi vous allez sur un petit site
là comme ça vous n'avez pas envie qu'on
prenne toutes vos informations
identifiant et c'est dans la benne nord
bp m
personnellement j'utilise dans ce cadre
là notamment quand je voyage mais
j'utilise aussi pour avoir accès à
certains sites qui peuvent être bloqués
en france je n'en dirai pas plus mais je
peux vous dire que je ne suis pas une
merde aussi vous permettre d'accéder à
netflix us netflix japon subventions
nous ait besoin par exemple à se faire
la halle aux états unis avalon temps
elle voulait continuer à regarder ses
contenus en france j'étais pas
disponible aux états unis
non lui pied en tout cas moi voilà c'est
pour ça que j'utilise régulièrement ce
service via un service après-vente 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 en français
c'est important le signaler et où il
avoir sur pleins d'appareils différents
genres ordi tablettes smartphones etc
d'habitude je vous montre sur mon
smartphone vous savez j'ai un iphone
mais j'ai des images où je le montrais
sur smartphone regarder voilà est donc
là admettons j'aurais de me connecter en
france bîmes quick connect et c'est
super et hyper v m je peux aussi par
exemple choisir de me connecter depuis
les etats unis
c'est rapide efficace fiable ça marche
bien encore une fois sur le plan de deux
ans vous avez un mois gratos évidemment
c'est satisfait ou remboursé ça que vous
pouvez vous rétracter pas d'engagement
et merci à eux 2 sponsorisé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à balancer vos histoires
c'est marrant de lire vos histoires en
versements faits ses intérêts ce que
j'essaye vous ai remarqué de prendre pas
mal de distance par rapport à ce qui
vous arrive j'espère que vous comprenez
que ce format vous plaira et encore
beaucoup beaucoup d'histoires de ce que
m'a dit elle fuit quand il ya de quoi
faire pas mal de vidéos il m'a dit aussi
qu'ils avaient des histoires qui était
folle mais qu'il a refusé parce qu'elle
venait pas d' une adresse mail
totalement anonymisée via les services
que gémir déception donc si vous pensez
que votre histoire est folle et que
voulait pas envoyer d'une adresse mail
totalement anonyme
comme j'avais demandé n'hésitez pas à la
renvoyer et dernière chose j'ai rajouté
un nous
au créneau sur twitch donc je serai
maintenant sur twitter le mardi à 22h
pour faire durer actes vous le savez
mais j'y serai aussi le mercredi à 19h30
c'est à dire après la sortie cette vidéo
est là ce sera pas durer avec ça peut
être d'autre chose genre par exemple du
gaming
ça peut être j'en sais rien je me laisse
vraiment libre cours je fais vraiment ce
que je veux sur ce créneau le mardi je
laisse le riz actes parce que ça marche
bien ça vous plaît bien et c'est le
mercredi on peut s'attendre à tout et
embrasse fort bon courage à toutes
celles et ceux à qui j'ai lu les
histoires et qui passe par des moments
difficiles
bon courage aussi à celles et ceux que
j'ai pas eu les histoires et qui passe
par des moments difficiles forces et
soutiens à vous toutes et tous love
peace chao jeudi chocolatines alors que
je suis de l'est je fais peut-être ça
uniquement parce que je veux être à
contre courant car je suis et
concentrique suis-je une merde
non non ce n'est pas une merde mais
c'est marrant
[Musique]